there are people out there who believe
in god
what they struggle with is really the
role
of priests of nuns of people who feel
they are this passageway for example
you can walk into a room get training
and do an exorcism
and they struggle with that because they
say well this is just a person this is
just another person like me
and what do you say to people who doubt
organized religion because they doubt
the ability of regular people
to be passageways for
god the holy spirit what do you say to
them about
you about
why they should believe that you are
capable of
channeling god in that way
i would respond by saying that everyone
has a vocation
and the word vocation means a calling
from god
the god has a plan for all of us
and as a priest again it's not what i'm
doing again if people are relying on me
we're in trouble
but again
priests religious sisters you think of
pastors rabbis imams
anyone who's dedicating their life to
god
we could say that they're
you know i'm not dragging people to
heaven but one can act as a conduit
one can allow their life to be used by
god
as a way to bring others to god because
ultimately we're all on the same journey
together it's not at the end of the day
we get to look at each other and laugh
and say ha ha i got a bigger piece of
god than you do
so i don't believe that we're in a sense
of competition i think we're
we're all on a search
for ultimate meaning and purpose truth
if you will
and ultimately that's found in god
and i think anyone who dedicates their
life to god
it's just out there
as a way to remind people
that god does have
his rightful place to play in the course
of human history
how do you feel about when it comes to
the exorcisms regular people um trying
to do what you do
can um can for example even in a broader
sense
someone like me for example right say
i'm catholic i go i get holy water
that's been blessed and now can i
utilize that holy water to bless someone
else like what are the limitations of
what a regular person can do in this
hemisphere of exorcisms of blessing
someone of being that conduit
my first response goes to a line in
scripture where the disciples return and
they say
lord we saw someone casting out demons
you know in your name and we tried to
stop them because they're not in our
company and jesus said well don't stop
them because anyone who's not against us
is for us
so i do believe i mean
many of the saints of the church saint
catherine of siena used to do exorcisms
not by any formula but simply walking
down the street because
of her holiness and virtue
demons couldn't even stand to be in her
presence
but the rite of exorcism is a liturgical
right so there is a prescribed way for
it to be done but people can be
delivered by
other means because again ultimately
jesus is the exorcist
and he can work where he chooses but
again as a liturgical right of the
church
there is a ritualized way that the
catholic church
performs exorcisms if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]